احييكم مشاهدينا واهلا بكم الى هذه
التغطيه للعربيه والمتواصله لتطورات
المشهد في السودان دول عده في سباق مع
الزمن لاجلاء رعاياها فيما يشهد محيط
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه اشتباكات
متقطعه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
اعداد القتلى وصلت الى 420 شخصا اما
الجرحى فقدناهز عددهم الاربعه الاف بحسب
منظمه الصحه العالميه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وفي اخر تطورات الميدانيه اعلن الجيش
السوداني عبر التلفزيون الرسمي السيطره
الكامله على مدينه الاوبيض اصبحت مدينه
الاوبيض الان امنه سالمه هانئه مطمئنه
ندعو جميع المواطنين لفتح الاسواق ومزاوله
اعمالهم من صباح الغد
الله اكبر
اصبحت المدينه امنه مطمئنه
كما بث الجيش مشاهد لسيطره قواته على
معسكر للدعم السريع في ام درمان نتابع
[موسيقى]
ودائما نذكر بالاخبار العاجله التي تصلنا
على شاشه العربيه الجيش السوداني يتحدث عن
اجلاء
بعثتين القطريه والاردنيه الى بورتسودان
كما قال الجيش السوداني نجاح اجلاء بعثات
دبلوماسيه عده ورعايه بعض الدول اذا حسب
الجيش السوداني نجح الجيش السوداني باجلاء
بعثات دبلوماسيه عده ورعايه لعده دول كما
تحدث عن اجلاء البعثتين القطريه والاردنيه
الى بورتسودان وما يحدث مشاهدينا في
السودان لم يبقى داخله سباعيه افريقيه قد
تتاثر بتفاقم النزاع اكثر فخروج دويه
الانفجارات وقتال الشوارع عن مساحه
المليون و880 الف كيلو متر مربع ليس
مستبعدا جوله اولى من حرب اهليه قد تمتد
الى سبع دول يتشارك السودان حدودا ملتهبه
معها بالاستناد الى عاملين مدى استمراريه
ونتيجته
حقائب موظبه وسرر محموله على الراس احد
مخاوف السباعيه المحيطه بالسودان وليس
اكبرها كوابيس تتسرب عبر السدود وانابيب
المياه وتتمل بعتاد حركات مسلحه عبر
الحدود التي باتت بيئه اكثر خصوبه للتمرد
اجلس الانذار التي تدق اقليميا ودوليا لا
تنحصر بكون السودان ثالث اكبر دوله في
افريقيا بل لانه يمتد عبر منطقه حيويه
جيوسياسيا غير مستقره وهشه ببعض اجزائها
مصر المتعطشه للمياه اكثر دوله عربيه
اكتظاظا بالسكان وتتشارك مع السودان
تاريخا من السياسه والتجاره والثقافه
ومياه النيل فضلا عن علاقات وثيقه بالجيش
واكثر من اربعه ملايين سودانيين على
اراضيها واي اضطراب بالعمق الاستراتيجي
لمصر من شانه عرقله الجهود المشتركه
للتوصل
بشان صد النهضه التهديد المائي ليس فقط ما
تشكله اثيوبيا بطموحاتها الكهرومائيه
فالمناوشات على الحدود غير منقطعه اصلا
وقد يتسبب النزاع بعوده التوتر بمنطقه
الفشجه الخصبه الحدوديه المتنازع عليها
تشاد الجاره الغربيه الفقيره تحتضن بالاصل
نحو 400 الف نازح سوداني جراء صراعات
سابقه اضيف اليهم اكثر من عشرين الفا
مؤخرا القلق التشادينا بعلم من مخاوف
امتداد الازمه لمناطق استقبلت اللاجئين
ومعظمهم من دارفور فتاريخ تشاد طويل مع
ميليشيات الجنجويد التي شكلت نواه قوات
احمدتي
قلق مشابه يتكون غربا مرتزقه ومسلح
ميليشيات سودانيون عادوا الى بلادهم بعد
لعب دور النشط في الصراع الليبي هؤلاء على
معرفه جيده بالساحه الليبيه ومطاردتهم
داخليا قد ترميهم على الحدود مجددا اما
جنوب السودان الدوله التي استقلت حديثا
فمخاوفها تتمثل ببدء عرقله الروابط
اللوجستيه لتصريف انتاجها النفطي البالغ
170 الف برميلا يوميا عبء اقتصادي قد
تزيده سوءا عوده جماعيه لاكثر من 800 الف
لاجئ يستضيفهم السودان ازمه تتشاركها مع
اريتريا فمئه من مواطنيها قد يضطرون لحزم
امتعتهم من جديد
نعود ان نذكر بكل الاخبار العاجله الصادره
من الجيش السوداني حيث يقول بانهم يواصلون
بقيه عمليات الاجلاء تباعا حسب الطلبات
التي قدمت من الدول قال بان القاعده التي
اجليت البعثات منها هي قاعده وادي سيدنا
في الخرطوم ايضا الجيش السوداني تحدث عن
ان بعثات امريكا وبريطانيا وفرنسا
والمانيا اجليت من قاعده قرب الخرطوم
وان الجيش السوداني قام باجلاء البعثتين
القطريه والاردنيه الى بورتسودان وبانه
نجح باجلاء البعثه الدبلوماسيه عده ورعايا
بعض الدول اذا هذه ابرز الاخبار العاجله
الوارده على لسان الجيش السوداني اذا ايضا
الجيش السوداني يتحدث الان عن تحركات لدعم
استمرت بالخرطوم باستلائها على مرافق
استراتيجيه وتخريبها اذا الجيش السوداني
يتحدث عن تحركات الدعم التي استمرت
بالخرطوم استلائها على مرافق استراتيجيه
وتخريبها نتابع الان مقالته الخارجيه
المصريه بان القاهره اجلت 436 مواطنا برا
من السودان وكانت مصادر العربيه افادت في
وقت سابق ان الجيش المصري نسق مع نظيره
السوداني عمليات الاجلاء كما اشارت مصادر
العربيه ان الجيش السوداني تولى مرافقه
قوافل المصريين حتى المعابر الحدوديه وان
السودان زودت مصر بتفاصيل الممرات الامنه
لنقل المصريين لاماكن الاجلاء وكانت مصر
نشرت قوات امنيه على معابرها الحدوديه مع
السودان لتامين عمليات الاجلاء
من القاهره تنضم الينا مديره مكتب العربيه
في مصر رنده ابو العزم رنده اهلا بك معنا
ماذا لدينا من جديد حول عمليه الاجلاء
نعم ميسون بحسب ما ذكرتي الان ربما اخر
بيان للخارجي المصريه هو النجاح في اجلاء
436 مصري ابتدى تحدثنا مع اسره احد
المصريين الذين نجحوا في الوصول بالفعل
الى المنفذ وهو منفذ ارقين هناك منفذان
بريان منفذ ارقين ومنفذ قسط الاشكيت هو
وصل بحسب اسرته الى منفذ ارقين عند في
الجانب السوداني الان يستعد للدخول الى
مصر ومنها الى محافظه في شبين الكوم وهي
رحله طويله جدا امتدت منذ فجر الامس لربما
ستمتد الى فجر الغد اذا ما وصل
وجد حافله اذا هذه الرحله قد تستغرق ثلاثه
ايام للوصول الى المحافظات المختلفه ولكنه
على الاقل نجح في الوصول او في الخروج
امنا عبر هذه الدفعه الدفعه الاولى هناك
دفعات ثانيه كما نعلم ان مصر الان
لاصق لوجود خطه خطه اجلاء طوارئ خطه
الاجلاء الطوارئ دي بحسب ما علمنا من
المصادر
ستكون
بعد تشكيل غرفه عمليات مشتركه او مركزيه
ستكون هناك
خطه طوارئ من العمليات الخاصه لتامين خروج
المصريين العالقين في اماكن
الاشتباكاترون على الورقات ولكن المريض ان
ننوه بالاخبار العاجله الوارده الان من
الجيش السوداني الذي يتحدث عن ان قوات
الدعم تعتدي على دار الهاتف بالخرطوم
وتقطع الانترنت بشبكه سوداني ايضا قال بان
قوات الدعم تقيم نقاط التفتيش ببعض مناطق
الخرطوم لاعاقه حركه المواطنين
واعاد وذكر بان تحركات الدعم استمرت في
الخرطوم باستيلائها على مرافق استراتيجيه
وتخريبها اذا الجيش السوداني
تباعا يتحدث عن تحركات قوات الدعم السريع
كما ذكر الان بان قوات الدعم السريع تقتحم
بعض السجون وتجبر الشرطه على اطلاق من
فيها ايضا هذه ابرز
العواجل التي تاتينا تباعا على لسان الجيش
السوداني تفضل لرندا اعود اليك
كنت اتحدث ان هناك خطه طوارئ وضعت تحت
اشراف الاجهزه الامنيه
المصريه لتتعامل مع العالقين المصريين في
الاماكن المشتعله داخل السودان وتم اعطاء
ضوء اخضر للتعامل مع الحالات العالقه هناك
ايضا قوات خاصه مشتركه تقوم بالمهام
الخارجيه ستكون مهمتها اجلاء المصريين
هناك ايضا بحسب المصادر للعربيه ميسون
هناك غرفه عمليات مركزيه بتتابع عمليات
الاجلاء وجهت حاليا باعداد خريطه او خارطه
طريق للاماكن التي بها مخاطر مرتفعه
لاجلاء المصريين منها قبل نهايه الاسبوع
فجر الاثنين او فجر الغد سيشهد وتيره اسرع
في التعامل مع عمليات اجلاء المصريين
سيكون هناك طرق مختلفه في التعامل بشكل
اكبر ايضا يعني كل فئه من من الفئات
المتواجده في السودان بحسب شده الخطوره
المكان المتواجد فيها سيتم التعامل معها
تحدثنا مع بعض
من هم متواجدون في الخرطوم وهي مكان يعني
شديد الخطوره معظم الطلاب متواجدين في
شارع اسمه شارع الستين تحدثنا معهم وهم في
يعني في حاله ذعر لانه لا يوجد ادويه لا
يوجد امدادات غذائيه
كان هناك احد الحالات المصابه بتلقي ناري
لا يجد الاسعاف يعني ما يشهده السودانيين
يشهدوا ايضا المصريون العالقون هناك من
نجح في الخروج من الخرطوم ولكن كان هناك
مطالبه او مناشده من الخارجيه المصريه
بعدم خروج اي من المصريين في الاماكن
شديده الخطوره على الاقل اليوم
اما بالنسبه اعداد اعداد المتواجده يتم
التنسيق مع هؤلاء الذين يريدون الخروج من
السودان هل عبر السفاره فقط
والقنصليات في السودان ام هناك مثلا على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
هناك بعض الارشادات التي تعطى لهم او
تعطيهم ارشادات اين يتجهون الى اي محطات
كيف ياخذون الباصات لانه عبر مواقع
التواصل كنا نشاهد بعض من يضع معلومات اذا
اردتم ان تنتقلوا من السودان الى مصر ما
هي الطريقه او ما هي الشركات هل هذا الامر
حقيقي ام فقط تداول على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي
لا هذا امر حقيقي بالفعل ومن غادر بالامس
تواصل عبر هذه المواقع ولكن بحسب ما ذكر
لي ان الاسعار كانت مرتفعه للغايه يعني من
كان يستقل حافله قبل الاحداث ب 30 دولار
الان بيدفع اكثر من 300 او 400 500 دولار
هناك استغلال لهذه الحالات ولكن ايضا
وزاره الخارجيه المصريه منذ اول امس
واليوم بدات في ايضا نشر ارقام هواتف
للتواصل مع الجاليه المصريه المتواجده في
السودان او حتى مع اهالي المصريين
المتواجدين اما بالنسبه للاعداد وهنا يعني
هذا امر مهم للغايه اعداد المصريين
المتواجدين في السودان اعداد بالالاف
وليست بالمئات ولهذا بتوجد صعوبه كبيره في
اخراج كل هذه الاعداد
يعني خلافا لمن يتم اجلائهم من جنسيات
اخرى بتصل اعدادهم للمئات هنا نتحدث لالاف
الاعداد الرسميه في الخرطوم وحدها ربما
تصل الى عشره الاف الاعداد غير الرسميه
تفوق الخمسين الف اذا نحن نتكلم عن الاف
المصريين كيفيه خروجهم وتامينهم سواء برا
او جوا او بحر او بحرا هذه عمليه شديده
التعقيد بتقوم بها السلطات المصريه منذ
اليوم واتباعا بحسب ايضا وتيره الاحداث
ايضا هناك مبادرات مصريه
بالطرق الدبلوماسيه للوصول الى هدنه ممتده
وايضا ايقاف اطلاق النيران على الاقل في
المناطق السكنيه
والمستشفيات ومحاوله ادخال المساعدات
الانسانيه والمساعدات الطبيه باشراف ايضا
كل هذا سيشكل نوع من تخفيف الوضع الانساني
المتفاقم جدا في السودان الذي يعاني منه
الشعب السوداني هناك ايضا نقطه اخرى مهمه
جدا هو تجديد
التواجد الامني في المعابر او حول المعابر
لان هذه نقطه مهمه كانت مسيره ان عناصر من
جماعه الاخوان كانت قد هربت من مصر عام
2013 يمكن ان تحاول التسلل مره اخرى
بهويات مزوره اذا هناك
تحسب لهذه العناصر هناك تجديد امني كبير
جدا على كافه المعابر
او دخول سواء المصريين او حتى من
السودانيين حتى الان ايضا من المتوقع ايضا
ان يدخل اعداد من السودانيين ولكن لابد من
اثبات هويتهم تفضلي شكرا لك من القاهره
مديره مكتب العربيه في مصر رنده ابو العزم
على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
قالت وزاره الخارجيه الاثيوبيه انما يحدث
في السودان شان داخلي وان اثيوبيا مستعده
للوساطه اذا طلب منها ذلك واضافت الخارجيه
الاثيوبيه ان اديس ابابا تسعى لتهدئه
الاوضاع في السودان بعيدا عن التقارير
الوهميه مشيره الى انه لا صح للتقارير
التي تتحدث عن تدخل لاتيوبيا في السودان
وشددت الخارجيه الاثيوبيه على انها تراقب
عن كثب وضع الجاليه الاثيوبيه الموجوده في
السودان
الى ذلك صرح وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان
العربيه بان جنوب السودان قامت باستقبال
اكثر من ثلاثه الاف لاجئ من السودان
ومستعده لاستقبال المزيد منهم كما قال ان
رئيس جنوب السودان اجرى مكالمه هاتفيه مع
الرئيس المصري لحتى البرهان على الموافقه
لوقف اطلاق النار
لقد قمنا باستقبال مجموعه من السودانيين
لسنوات عده وامنا ما ولاهم ونحن سعيدون
لهذا ولدينا اكثر من ثلاثه الاف لاجئ من
السودان يعيشون بكرامه في جنوب السودان
ونحن مستعدون لاستقبال المزيد منهم ان
رئيسنا اجر مكالمه هاتفيه مع الرئيس
المصري وتطرق للوضع الحالي وكيف يمكنهم
العمل على حث البرهان لوقف اطلاق النار
والعوده الى طاوله المفاوضات وذلك لوقف
الخلافات بين الطرفين المتحاربين
اتهامات متبادله بين قائد الجيش السوداني
عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان المعروف بحماتي فخلال
لقائهما غير المباشر عبر العربيه اتهم كل
طرف الاخر ببدء الحرب وخرق الهدنه والهجوم
على منازل السكان والبعثات الاجنبيه نتابع
البرهان وحميدتي جنرالاني جنح الى الحرب
بعد ان كان السودان قاب قوسين او ادناه من
توقيع اتفاق تاريخي العربيه جمعت البرهان
وحماتي على شاشتها في حوار غير مباشر
بينهما في مقابلتين خاصتين من بدا الحرب
من يسيطر على العاصمه وما ابرز اماكن وجود
قوات كل طرف
الجيش على مطار الخرطوم في مطار نياله في
اشكاليه نعم هنالك وجود لمجموعات كثيره
جدا من هذه القوات وسط
الاحياء
المهندسين
اين يوجد البرهان وحميتي انا موجود في
هيئه قياده القوات المسلحه
ومضارحه ولن ابارحها
من اخرج الا محمولا على
من خلق الهدنه اي هدنه اعلنت اصلا ما في
حتى ابتدات لانه يعني القوات الطرف الاخر
غير تسيطر عليها وهي منتشره في مناطق
مختلفه من الحياه السكنيه
من اختار الحرب عوض السلام اليوم احنا
قلنا موجودين في مقرات
نا نريد ان نخرج نخرج الى خارج دائره
الدفاع
من يستهدف المستشفيات والبعثات الاجنبيه
كيف ستنتهي المعركه
لم تعلم
هذه الحرب انا اقول ان هذه الحرب ليس فيها
كاسد
اعلن المتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه في
السودان خالد عمر يوسف ان النزاع الحالي
في السودان سيكون سببا في ضياع البلاد دون
استعادتها مؤكدا انها حرب لن ينتصر فيها
اي طرف يوسف اشار الى ما اعتبرها فرصه
متاحه حاليا لايقاف الحرب وتشكيل جبهه
مدنيه لتجاوز الازمه الراهنه كما اكد على
اهميه واولويه اجتماع الاطراف العسكريه
والمدنيه على طاوله الحوار للتوصل الى حل
دائم
من لندن تنضم الينا الكاتب الصحفي
السودانيه مروه الحاجه مروه اهلا بك معنا
ماذا لديك من معلومات حول اخر التطورات في
السودان وهل الهدوء مازال سيد الموقف طبعا
هدوء حذر يعني خلال هذه الهدنه التي اطلقت
منذ يومين
اهلا بك بالتاكيد هنالك هدوء في هذا اليوم
لكنه كما ذكرت
مشوب بالحذر الكبير ربما تكون هنالك بعض
العاده بعض
مظاهر الحياه للبعض خرجوا الى الاسواق
وقاموا بشراء
مستلزماتهم لكن هذا لا يعني ان الامر او
الامن قد استتبى بصوره طبيعيه نحن في
نهايه المهله في ساعات الاخيره من الهدنه
ربما تنتهي خلال ساعات قلائل
ويوم غد قد يشهد تطور نوعي في طبيعه
الصراع بين الطرفين الجيش
ان يكون هناك تصعيد نوعي في تقديري ان
الهدنه التي
الهدنه الحاليه التي يعيشها سكان السودان
او سكان على وجه التحديد انها كانت يستهدف
بها ايدياء الدول الغربيه والاقليميه
لرعاي
اها اساتها الدبلوماسيه داخل الخرطوم اما
وقد تم الايداع فهذا لا يشير الى امر جيد
في تقدير ربما تكون هنالك مواجهه حاميه
الوطيس بين الطرفين بعد اجلاء البعثات
الدبلوماسيه ورعايه بعد الدول عايشنا ذلك
كثيرا خلال فتره
الثوره ثوره ديسمبر 2019 في السودان قاطبه
كانت خاصه لا سيما انه لاول مره ومنذ
اندلاع الحرب يتم قطع شبكه الانترنت من
السودان وفي كل مره كان يتم فيها قطع شبكه
الانترنت من السودان كانت تحصل مجازر
هائله في تلك الفتره لذلك جلم ما نخشاه
الان ان يكون القطع شبكه الانترنت في
السودان الان تمهيد
لتغطيه بعض الفظائع التي ربما ترتكب في
الساعات القادمه
بالنسبه ايضا
الوضع الامني في السودان خاصه في الخرطوم
يعني كان سيء جدا خلال هذه الايام التسعه
الى اي مدى استطاع الناس يعني غير البعثات
الدبلوماسيه ورعايا الدول الاخرى الناس
داخل الخرطوم هل تمكنوا ايضا من النزوح
الى مناطق اكثر امنا
الشعب السوداني في الخرطوم الان يعيش او
الدعاء
انسانيه حرجه جدا على كافه المستويات على
الصعيد الامني على الصعيد الغذائي على كل
المستويات هنالك نزوح كبير جدا جدا من
الخرطوم الى الولايات القريبه والمحيطه
بولايه الخرطوم كما هنالك حالات لجوء
جماعي للدول القريبه والمحيطه بالسودان
البعض ذهب الى جنوب السودان البعض يفكر في
الذهاب الى اثيوبيا رغم انها الازعب
الاصعب من بين دول الجوار لطول المسافه
وما الى ذلك لكن كميات كبيره جدا جدا خرجت
من ولايه الخرطوم واتجهت شمالا الى
جمهوريه مصر العربيه اعداد كبيره جدا لا
حصر لها هنالك ايضا اعداد كبيره
ذهبت الى تشاد
الحرب الدائره تسعه ايام خلفت الكثير
الكثير من النازحين الكثير من اللاجئين
الكثير من الذين تنعدم لديهم ابسط مقومات
الحياه ماء وطعام
وغيره حتى ان الحاله الامنيه ليست الحاله
الامنيه المتعلقه بالقصف والطيران
والمدافع الثقيله وهكذا بل الحاله الامنيه
المتعلقه
بعملياتها السلب والنهب التي انتظمت
البيوت والتي انتظمت
المصانع حتى حتى طلمبات البنزين لم تسلم
من النهب والسلب
ساعود اليك بهذه النقطه ولكن اسمحي لي ان
ايضا نتحدث عن عمليات الاجلاء ان كان
الدول الاوروبيه او الدول العربيه الاخرى
ومن ثم اعود لمتابعه النقاش معك الاتحاد
الاوروبي اعلن اجلاء بعث في السودان بامان
وكان ممثل السياسه الخ ارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيفوريل قال انه حتى قائدي
الجيش السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد
قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو على
الوقف الفوري لاطلاق النار واضاف بوريل
انه اكد للبرهان ودجلو ضروره حمايه
المدنيين
وهذا خبر عاجل الجيش السوداني يتهم الدعم
السريع بقطع الاتصالات والانترنت في
الخرطوم اذا الجيش يتهم الدعم السريع بقطع
الانترنت والاتصالات في الخرطومات نتابع
ايضا من اجلاء حكومات اجنبيه دبلوماسيين
وموظفين واخرين محاصرين في السودان في
الوقت الذي يشتبك فيه القاده العسكريون
المتنافسون لليوم التاسع من دون اي مؤشر
على تهدئه قريبه
لم يصمت الرصاص في السودان في هدن تم
الاتفاق عليها ما دفع الدول للبدء بعمليات
اجلاء رعاياها تحت النار تصدرت السعوديه
الدول التي اجلت رعاياها ورعاي دول اخرى
باول عمليه اجلاء لمدنيين حيث نقلت القوات
البحريه السعوديه اكثر من 150 شخصا من
السعوديين ورعاي دول اخرى من بورسودان الى
جده عبر البحر الاحمر
ووسطى تبادل الجيش وقوات حملت الاتهامات
بشان اطلاق النار اثناء عمليه اجلاء رعايه
فرنسيين كان احدها هؤلاء الرعايه قد اصيب
ولفتت الخارجيه الفرنسيه الى ان اجلاء
رعاياها يشمل ايضا مواطنين اوروبيين ودول
حليفه بدورها بدات بريطانيا والمانيا
واسبانيا في اجلاء رعاياها كما ارسلت
اليونان طائرات وقوات خاصه الى مصر
استعدادا لاجلاء 120 يونانيا وقبرصيا من
الخر
وبخلاف الرعب الذي يحرم حول عمليات
الاجلاء المهدده باشتعال القتال في اي وقت
فهناك تعقيدات اخرى منها شلل المطار
الرئيسي اضافه الى ايقاف تشغيل المطارات
الاخرى في انحاء السودان حنان المصري
العربيه
اعلنا وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه عن اغلاق
السفاره البريطانيه في الخرطوم مؤقتا
مؤكدا ان سلامه البريطانيين في السودان
تشكل اولويه قصوى بالنسبه لهم
لقد اتخذنا قرارا باغلاق السفاره
البريطانيه في الخرطوم مؤقتا واجلال
الدبلوماسيين البريطانيين وعائلاتهم ونقل
وظائفنا الدبلوماسيه الى موقع دبلوماسي
قريب ونواصل العمل بشكل مباشر من خلال
شركائنا الدوليين للدعوه الى وقف اطلاق
النار ووضع حد لهذا العنف تبقى سلامه
حمايه الرعايه البريطانيه في السودان
اولويه قصوى بالنسبه لنا وسنقوم بهذا
الواجب من خلال سفاراتنا الموجوده في
المنطقه بالتنسيق الوثيق مع اصدقائنا
وشركائنا الدوليين
من جانبه اكد وزير الدفاع البريطاني
بينوال ان عمليه اجراء الموظفين
دبلوماسيين البريطانيين وعائلتهم تمت
بنجاح مشيرا الى انه شارك في عمليه
الاجلاء اكثر من 1200 شخص
الليله الماضيه اجرى الجيش البريطاني
عمليه اجلاء للموظفين الدبلوماسيين
البريطانيين وعائلاتهم من الخرطوم
باستخدام عناصر من اللواء السادس عشر هجوم
جوي وسلاح الجو الملكي ومشات البحريه
الملكيه ساهم اكثر من 1200 شخص في هذه
العمليه المحفوفه بالمخاطر لكننا مع ذلك
تمكنا من استخدام طائرات سيمي 130 وايه
400 للدخول وجمع دبلوماسيين والمقيمين
معهم والطيران الى بر الامان
اعد مجددا الى ضيفه من لندن الكاتبه
الصحفيه السودانيه مروه الحاج مروه كنت
تتحدثي عن عمليات النهب والسرقه التي تحصل
في الخرطوم حتى ان والي الخرطوم ايضا كان
دعا الى
تشكيل لجان لحمايه الاحياء هل هذا كافن هل
تستطيع هذه اللجان حمايه الاحياء في
الخرطوم
في هذا التوقيت لا تستطيع اي جهه مدنيه
حمايه
[موسيقى]
المقرات او حمايه المواطنين لان
هنالك مقاطع تهدد المواطنين اذا ما خرجوا
الى الشارع بالكاد بالكاد المواطنين
يخرجون الى الشارع لجلب مستلزماتهم
الاساسيه التي يحتاجونها لكي يعيشوا على
الاقل لا اعتقد ان بامكان اي احد الخروج
الى الشارع وهو مستهدف اما من الجماعات
التي تقوم بعمليات السلب الودنه او مستهدف
اما من القصف الموجه من الجيش السوداني او
القصف الموجه من قوات الدعم السريع
الوضع الامني لا يسمح اطلاقا لاي مدني بان
يكون خارج منزلي وحتى مروه من معرفه لمن
تابعه هي هذه التنظيمات
[موسيقى]
وهذه الافراد التي تقوم بعمليات السلب
والنهب
ليس هناك ما يشير لانها تتبع لي جهه محدده
ولكن الاطراف المعتاد تتبادل الاتهامات
فيما بينها الجيش السوداني ينسبها الى
الدعم السريع والدعم السريع يدعي بان
الجيش السوداني لديه جنود يلبسون اللبس
الدعم السريع ويقومون بهذه العمليات
لتشويه صوره الدعم السريع لدى المواطنين
السودانيين وشيطنتهم
ويقول انه متعودون على ذلك
لماذا حتى الان لم نتمكن من الحصول على
هذا الاطفاء القادر على اطفاء النيران
الموجوده الان في في السودان وهذا السلاح
وهذا الاشتباك المسلح في تقديري لانعدام
الاراده السياسيه
القوى السياسيه الموجوده الان في الساحه
السياسيه السودان وانعدام الاراده
السياسيه ايضا والجنوح للسلم بين
القائدين عبد الفتاح البرهان
ومحمد حمدان
هذه الاطراف جميعها تفتقد الاراده
السياسيه التي
تدعو الى وقف هذا هذا النزيف
المستمر في تقدير ان الجهود المبذوله حتى
داخليا وخارجيا لوقف هذه الحرب لم تستطيع
ان تقنع الطرفين بالجنوح للسلم وبوقف
الحرب والجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات لاجراء
مباحثات حول
كيف يمكن الوصول الى تسويه سياسيه برايك
المصالحه ما زالت ممكنه بين
حماتي وبين البرهان بعد كل هذا التصعيد ان
كلامي او حتى هذه الاشتباكات على الارض
لا اعتقد انه الان هنالك مجال لاي اتفاق
بين الطرفين وهنالك تصريحات كثيره صرح بها
الطرفان بان مهمه كل واحد منهما جل ما
يسعى اليه هو القضاء على الاخر تماما
الجيش السوداني يريد القضاء على قوات
الدعم السريع بالكامل ويقول انه لن يتوقف
حتى يحقق هذا الهدف على الارض هل اي فريق
قادر على الغاء الاخر على الانتصار على
الاخر
حتى الان موازين القوى تبدو
متساويه بين الجانبين كل من الجانبين لديه
مواقع استراتيجيه يسيطرون عليها لديهم
طرق وشوارع ومدن يسيطرون عليها حتى ان
هنالك المكان الواحد اذا ما تم اخلاقه من
طرف يعود الطرف الاخر للاستيلاء عليه
وهكذا اذا
بين الجانبين مستمره لا يبدو ان هنالك قوه
حاسمه او ميزان القوه لا يميل بشده او
بقوه للطرف من الاطراف لذلك من الصعب جدا
التسهل
من الذي ستميل اليه او ترجح اليه كافه
ميزان
كثيره في السودان وفصائل مسلحه ولكن حتى
الان هي ملتزمه الحياد برايك هل ستبقى هذه
الفصائل على حيادها ام هي بانتظار ان ترى
الى من تميل كفه الانتصار
بالضبط هنالك الكثير من حركات ما تسمى
بحركات الكفاح المسلحه التي تت داخل
الخرطوم وهي تشاهد الان عن بعد ما يدور في
الساحه العسكريه بين
الفريقين البرهان
وفي تقديرها انها تنتظر
لرؤيه مؤشرات
الانتصار الى اين يشير مؤشر الانتصار هل
الى الجيش ام الى الدعم السريع فيما ذلك
في تقدير انه سيقومون
بدعم احد الطرفين لكن في كل الاحوال
السيناريوهات المتوقعه لهذه الحرب ربما
تكون لصالح البرهان لكنه اذا ما انتصر في
هذه الحرب والمعرفه سيقوم في مواجهه
مفتوحه مع مؤيدين الاتفاق الاقاري سوى
كانوا بالقوى الحريه والتغيير او من داخل
مجلس السياده ذات نفسه تابعنا قبل يومين
تصريح لاحد اعطاء مجلس السياده الطاهره
حجر وهو يقول بان الحل
لهذه الازمه التي يعيشها السودان هو
التوافق على الاتفاق الاطاري وهو ما يرفضه
الجيش هو ما يرفضه البرهان السيناريو
الاخر حاله فوز حميد او انتصاره في هذه
المعركه ايضا سيكون في مواجهه مفتوحه مع
قاعده كبيره من السودانيين ترفض وجوه وجود
مليش الدعم السريع وتعتبرها ميليشيا قاتله
وسافكه للدماء وكذا رغم ان جميع تصريحاته
الاخيره
يقول يؤكد على الانتقال الديمقراطي
يقول انني ادعم الانتقال الديمقراطي وانه
حاله
ساقوم بتسليم الحكم الى حكومه مدنيه شكرا
لك من لندن الكاتبه الصحفيه السودانيه
مروه الحاج
افاد المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الاردنيه سنان
المجالي بانه تم اجلاءه اكثر من 300 شخص
بينهم رعايه لدول اخرى غير الاردن مشيرا
الى انه تم تنسيق مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لاجلاء الاردنيين من السودان
خطوه الاجزاء الاردنيه وصلت الحمد لله
لمراحلها النهائيه والحمد لله الطائرات
الاردنيه وصلت الى مطار بورسودان وهي الان
على على وشك الاقلاع باتجاه الاردن ان شاء
الله
عمليه الاجلاء او خطه الاجلاء كانت على
عده مراحل اللي قام فيها الاردن
وتكاد تكون من العمليات الكبيره اللي حدثت
في السودان بلغ عدد الاشخاص اللي اللي تم
اجلائهم او سيتم اجلائهم تقريبا يفوق ال
300 شخص من ضمنهم مواطنين من من دول صديقه
وشقيقه
عمليات اجلاء الاجانب من السودان
السعوديه اجلت واحد وتسعين مواطنا و66
شخصا من دول اخرى الى جده دفعه جديده
مرتقبه وصولها خلال ساعات
بريطانيا استكملت اجلاء موظفيها
الدبلوماسيين وعائلاتهم
المانيا طائره عسكريه هبطت في الخرطوم
لاجلاء رعاياها
فرنسا اجلت مئه شخص من السودان بطائرتين
من مطار قرب الخرطوم على ان يتبعهم 200
اخرون
الاردن ارسل اربع طائرات الى السودان
لاجلاء رعايه اردنيين وعرب وموظفين في
منظمات اغاثيه
مصر بدات باجلاء عشره الاف مصري عبر عمليه
محكمه وامنه ومنظمه
الولايات المتحده اجلت موظفي سفارتها
وعائلتهم ودبلوماسيين من دول اخرى
روسيا 140 روسيا من اصل 300 في السودان
يرغبون بالرحيل وهناك خطه لاجلائهم
تعمل كل من كوريا الجنوبيه والسويد
وهولندا وايطاليا لاجلاء مواطنها
نشد والي الخرطوم المكلف احمد عثمان حمزه
العاملين في الخدمات لتوفيرها قائلا ان
الظروف الحاليه تمنع الولايه من القيام
بمهامها ما جعله يطالب المنظمات بتقديم
الاسعاف للجرحى وتوفير مستلزمات المشافي
كما دعى المواطنين لتكوين لجان للتامين من
النهب والسرقه
هذا واعلنت منظمه الصحه العالميه ارتفاع
عدد الضحايا في السودان الى 420 قتيلا
وثلاثه الاف وسبعمائه كما اضافت انه لا
امكانيه حاليا لارسال المزيد من المعدات
الطبيه الجراحيه بسبب اغلاق المطارات
والطرق غير الامنه وحضرت من زياده سريعه
في عدد الوفيات سواء بسبب القتال او
المشاكل الصحيه خاصه مع استهداف المنشات
الصحيه
من لندن ينضم الى دكتور حسام طه المجمر
مؤسس منظمه اطباء السودان من اجل حقوق
الانسان دكتور اهلا بك معنى ماذا لديك من
معلومات حول القطاع الطبي والمستشفيات
اليوم في السودان اهلا بكم وشكرا
للاستضافه حسب التقرير من اللجنه
التمهيديه لاطباء السودان تقريرا رقم عشره
لصدر اليوم اليوم الثامنه للحرب صباح
اليوم الساعه 7:00 صباحا في عدد القتلى
وصل 264 قتيل وعدد عدد جرحى وصل الى
ومسحب انوه انه هذه الاعداد عباره عن
الاعداد
والجرحى والقتله وسط المدنيين الذين
رصدي في المستشفيات يعني احتمال العدد
يكون كبير جدا لانه الدكاتره ما قادرين
يوصلوا
الجرحى والقتله خارج المستشفيات ونحن
عارفين انه في صعوبه بالغه للوصول
للمستشفيات
الموجوده في مناطق النزاعات طب الاعداد
التي تحدثت عنها منظمه الصحه العالميه
برايك على ماذا استندت
والله هم عندهم البروتوكول بتاعهم اللي
بيشتغلوا لكن احنا في نقابه اللجنه
التنفيذيه لاطباء السودان من اعتمد
اعتمادا تامن على
[موسيقى]
الجرحى والقتل الذين وصلوا
الوضع المستشفيات يعني منذ اليوم الاول
ووضع المستشفيات كان سيئا جدا اليوم
ماذا يمكن ان تعطينا تفاصيل عن وضع
المستشفيات موضوع الكهرباء موضوع المياه
هل حلت هذه المشكله ام بعد
والله وضع المستشفيات
لهذه اللحظه في حاله مزريه جدا وعندنا 72%
من المستشفيات في مناطق الاشتباك
خارج عن الخدمه ومن اصل
79 مستشفى اساسيه في
العاصمه والولايات
57 منهم
متوقفه عن الخدمه يعني عندنا 22 مستشفى بس
شغال
متوقفه عن الخدمه بسبب الاشتباكات ام بسبب
عدم تواجد او عدم وجود الكهرباء عدم وجود
المياه عدم وجود الاطقم الطبيه المعدات
الطبيه والادويه
هي الاسباب كثيره يعني احنا عارفين انه في
المستشفى هي ضربت يعني
بالاسلحه واخليت وفي 19 مستشفى
من القواتل العسكريه
يعني هي اسباب متعدده لكن الاسباب الجسيمه
هي
الانتهاكات على المستشفيات
طبعا خارج القانون قانون الاشتباك نحن
بالنسبه للممرات الامنيه يعني خلال هذين
اليومين الى حد ما هناك هدوء حذر في
الخرطوم هل هناك من ممرات امنيه
استطاعت او سهلت عمل الاطقم الطبيه
والمستشفيات ام لا والله ما غير مؤكد
القتال من حين الاوقته يعني
بكون في اشتباكات
الوضع ليس امن
الاخوان في الاطباء والكوادر الطبيه هم
يعني بعرض حياتهم للخطر عشان يوصل
الامدادات للمستشفيات
خارج السودان هل من جهود تقومون بها
كمنظمه اطباء السودان من اجل حقوق الانسان
هل تقومون باي جهود لمساعده المستشفيات مع
المنظمات الدوليه
لنقوم بجهود مختصه في الاتصالات مع
جاهزيه
الامدادات اذا حصل اي انفراج في في الوضع
الامني انا على علم بانه بعض المنظمات عند
امدادات موجوده في عربات وفي مخازنه
لكن هم ما قادرين يوصلوا للمستشفيات لانه
الحاله غير امنه في الطرقات شكرا
دكتور حسام طه المجمر مؤسس منظمه اطباء
السودان
من الطالبه منظمه الصحه العالميه بعدم
استهداف المرافق الصحيه والعاملين والمرضى
في السودان بعدما وثقت المنظمه عده هجمات
مميته استهدفت المؤسسات الصحيه ويعاني
القطاع الطبيعي في السودان من اوضاع
الصعبه زادها النزاع والدائره حاليا سوءا
كما العاده في كل النزاعات والصراعات
المدنيون هم الضحيه الاكبر لها وهذا وضع
السوداني اليوم جثث ملقاه في الشوارع وما
من جهه تتمكن من نقلها لمثواها الاخير مع
تضارب الاحصاءات حول عدد القتلى بين
الجهات المحليه والدوليه فترات هدنه
متقطعه لم توفر ممرات امنه لتخفيف وطئه
النزاع وتاثيرها على المواطن السوداني
مكتب الشؤون الانسانيه بالامم المتحده رصد
مقتل 413 شخصا واصابه ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه
اخرين في الاشتباكات حتى الحادي والعشرين
من ابريل الجاري بحسب التقرير سجلت
الخرطوم اعلى عدد من القتله ب 132 ثلاث
ولايه شمال كردفان بخمسه وتسعين قتيلا ثم
ولايه شمال دارفور بواحد وستين قتيلا في
عدد المرشح للزياده المعوقات النحله
بنواجهك هلال احمد السوداني تواجهها كل
الانسانيه العامله في السودان اللي هي
ابرزه عدم توفر المسارات الامنه
وما في ضمانات لوقف اطلاق النار بين
الاطراف
تنازعة من جانبها اعلنت نقابه الاطباء ان
72 في المئه من المستشفيات القريبه من
مناطق الاشتباك توقفت عن الخدمه من اصل
تسعه وسبعين مستشفى اساسيا في العاصمه
والولايات من المجموع الكلي للمستشفيات
بقي اثنتان وعشرون مستشفى تعمل بشكل كامل
او جزئي لكنها تبقى مهدده بالاغلاق نتيجه
نقص الكوادر والامدادات الطبيه وانقطاع
الماء والكهرباء كما ان عده مناطق يكثر
فيها الجرحى لا تستطيع الطواقم الطبيه
الوصول اليها بيان نقابه الاطباء اضاف ان
اربعه مستشفيات في مدينه الاوبيض تعرضت
للقصف ما يرفع العدد الكلي للمستشفيات
التي قصفت الى 13 مستشفى يضاف اليها تسعه
عشر مستشفا تعرضت للاخلاء القصري كما
تعرضت ست مركبات اسعاف للاعتداء من قبل
قوات عسكريه بينما لم يتم لعدد من سيارات
الاسعاف بالمرور لنقل المرضى وايصال
المعونات حسب ما قالت نقابه اطباء السودان
من جانبه طالب الهلال الاحمر بتحييد
المنشات الطبيه عن العمليات القتاليه
لتجنب الانهيار الكامل للقطاع الصحي في
السودان حسن جوليد العربيه
وهذا الخبر العجل المصادر العربيات تتحدث
عن تاخير باجلاء بعض المصريين من السودان
لوجودهم في مناطق فيها اشتباكات اعني فاذا
حسب مصادر العربيه هناك تاخير لاجلاء
المصريين من السودان
لتواجدهم في مناطق تشهد اشتباكات عنيفه
صرح المسؤول الاعلامي للهلال الاحمر
السوداني العربيه انه لا توجد ممرات امنه
وموثوقه لايصال المساعدات الانسانيه
للاهالي في السودان
يعني المعوقات اللي احنا بنواجهك هلال
احمد السوداني تواجهها كل المنظمات
الانسانيه العامله في السودان اللي هي
ابرزه عدم توفر المسارات الامنه
وما في ضمانات لوقف اطلاق النار بين
الاطراف المتنازعه لهذا السبب الناس بتتجه
انها تقنع الاطراف المتنازعه ومش نحن بس
يعني كل المؤسسات الدوليه وحتى الامم
المتحده والحكومات بتسعى بين طرفيه النزاع
انه تامن اوقات معلومه ايام معلومه لوقف
اطلاق النار وضمان وصول المساعدات
الانسانيه لانه بدون ضمان امن الكادر
الكادر المسؤول عن توصيل المساعدات
الانسانيه حتبقى كارثه كبيره جدا
الشعب السودانيه اكثر من توى بنار هذه
الحرب القصه التاليه تحكي فقدان عائله
لابنها نتيجه سقوط مقذوف عليه في المنزل
في السودان الصراع متوصل بين المكونين
العسكريين
ايام المره يعيشها السودانيون الذين
تطلعوا لعهد جديد تميزه الديمقراطيه
[موسيقى]
حياه العشرات تحولت لماساه حقيقيه بسبب
تدهور الوضع الامني صراع تلو اخر عمق
الازمه وزاد من حده التممل والاستياء
ملامح الحزن والاسى خيمت على وجه ادريس
حسان الذي فقد ابن اخيه عندما اخترقت
قذيفه النافذه المنزل ادت لمقتله على
سريره
[موسيقى]
على العزال الليله فقدناه
والمرحوم ده مات في سريره
بس يعني
القصف تسبب بحروق لوالده الضحيه التي صدمت
من هول الحادثه
[موسيقى]
في السرير
الحياه المدنيه توقفت في السودان
مناطق سكنيه مقتظه بالسكان ومضخمه بالرصاص
[موسيقى]
موقع السودان المتميز في القاره الافريقيه
جعله عالقا بشبكه مصالح اقليميه ودوليه
واسعه تلقي بظلالها بشكل مستمر على مشهده
السياسي
لا هدنه صمدت ولا حسم يلوح بالافق نوبات
قتال شرعت لها ارض السودان الخصبه
للنزاعات مع غياب استعداد للتسويه شبكه من
المصالح والتقاطعات الاقليميه والدوليه
القت بظلالها على مشهد السودان السياسي
باستمرار في ظل موقعه الافريقي المتميز
ومساعي طي الازمه السياسيه افرز التقسيمات
في تعامل بعض الدول مع الازمه
علاقات الخرطوم المتميزه بالروس ليست
جديده تعد موسكو حليفا دبلوماسيا وعسكريا
لها تمكنت من خلالها توسيع حلقات تعاونها
الامني مع السودان خاصه مع امتلاك الاخير
موقعا مهما على البحر الاحمر المصالح وصلت
الى كنز السودان المدفون الذهب اتهم الغرب
مجموعه فاجن الروسيه بالتورط في انشطه غير
قانونيه لتعدين الذهب في السودان اما
بالنسبه للجناح الغربي وواشنطن فسعاد
التخلص من البشير التي تتهمه المحكمه
الدوليه بارتكاب جرائم حرب اثناء الصراع
في دارفور لم تملا تصدعات هذا البلد الهش
كما اتهمت واشنطن بالتلكؤ في دعم الانتقال
نحو اجراء انتخابات اما بالنسبه للصين يعد
السودان حلقه وصل مهمه بين المحيطين
العربي والافريقي لكنها تبنت نهجا اكثر
حذرا تجاه الصراع في السودان اتسعى الى
الحفاظ على التوازن بين مصالح الاقتصاديه
والالتزام بعدم التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه
للدول الاخرى
الصراع بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع اجتذب مشاركه كبيره من اللاعبين
الاقليميين والدوليين ولكل منهم دوافعه
ومصالحه الخاصه اياد حمود العربيه
[موسيقى]
الناس كلها كلها سكان هنا بتاع البحريه
يعني شبه كلها سكان يعني
احنا لنا ثمانيه ايام بالليل بدايه
الاحداث يعني لا تجد اننا ماء تماما ولا
يوجد عندنا كهرباء كنا في ظلام ظلام كده
مش عادي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات